allora
ho voluto iniziare con un
l'azione del dizionario e
mettiamo la scritta al centro aumentiamo
un pochettino ci vedete non può più
grande da allora per resilienza nella
residenza nella meccanica io ho aggiunto
nella vita e la capacità di un materiale
o di un essere umano non fa parte del
dizionario di essere di assorbire un
urto senza rompersi cioè di andare
avanti dopo che stesso che è successo un
problema mio ma andrea e sono nato a
napoli ho vissuto 18 anni lì ma essendo
mia madre di rimini e ho passato più o
meno quasi tutte le mie estati a qualche
chilometro da qui vivo a milano e
durante il e durante il mio percorso
professionale ho girato tanto sono stato
sono stato da 30 stata barcellona ho
vissuto a dublino misto a san francisco
è lavorato un paio d'anni per google due
anni e mezzo per vodafone e poi ha
creato la mia start up e lo venuta
l'anno scorso ho visto una quantità
illimitata di ted di teteks però poi
quando mi sono trovato davanti a questa
slide totalmente verde totalmente vuota
ho detto adesso cosa faccio
e quindi io ho usato il migliore amico
di tutti gli italiani anche sicuramente
il mio e ho chiesto google
ho fatto una domanda e ho scritto come
faccio a fare un telex spettacolare alto
mai segreto ed ex e la risposta è stata
divertentissima perché mi sono trovato
usa del testo grande delle slide
colorate partita perché fai ridere
ringrazio riassumi quindi elettore
iniziamo proviamoci
non è difficile serviamo google allora
ho cercato resilienza e ho detto vi
faccio vedere cosa succede quando si
parla di residenza su google google
immagini la prima immagine e una
piantina che cresce in un deserto
la seconda immagine di un albero chi si
piega ma non si spezza
probabilmente dovuto al vento di quel
posto la terza immagine e di una scritta
con scritto haicheng duet quindi non
posso farlo con una persona che taglia
la parte di non possono è quindi diventa
anche io posso farlo aic and white
oppure c'è tantissima gente è visto che
uno dei tatuaggi più interessanti di
tutti che si iscrive residenza sul corpo
così ogni mattina si sveglia legge
resilienza e inizia a fare la persona
residente ho fatto ridere quindi sono
riuscito benissimo
c'è scritto rendila personale nella
nella guida vendita personale allora vi
racconta due storie la prima quando
stava consegnando la presentazione una
settimana e mezzo fa il mio computer da
mattina quando l'ho aperto
esce il simbolo del divieto per tutte le
persone sono mac e vedono questo simbolo
vuol dire i tuoi dati sono stati
cancellati benissimo meraviglioso la
seconda mentre guardavo la tre curve la
uscita di rimini il sud
ieri e vedo la mia e l'avevo mai
totalmente bucata quindi benissimo mi
sono trovato a dover cambiare la gomma
poi ho capito che potevo fare il self
utilizzarlo durante la presentazione
quindi eccolo qui però l'idea è che se
mi aspettavo di fare una spettacolare
vacanza una passeggiata a rimini è stato
un po un nightmare queste due state
queste due opportunità sono state
sicuramente interessanti per far
crescere la mia resilienza
partiamo dal perché per chi dal perché
poi si passa al come e qualcosa quindi
quando vi racconto che cosa faccio e
cosa voglio fare dico perché io credo
che chi dà più 6 m non è una parolaccia
ragazzi è semplicemente un acronimo per
dire together we can achievment e quindi
se la mia mission è il mio perché è
questo il mio come organizzo questi
momenti di condivisione e di storie di
pensieri tra le persone tra le aziende
tra le attività ma andrea che cosa fai
veramente allora cosa faccio
faccio consulenza imprenditori ea start
up ea piccole e medie aziende su temi
della crescita
seconda cosa che faccio è organizzare
eventi organizzati dai 20 24 all'anno
sul mondo innovazione mancio il capo
degli stand entrepreneurship e poi
faccio lezione insegno insegnava le
università digital marketing and brand
neshat
quindi se together we can achievment
diventa in italiano insieme noi possiamo
fare di più non è la stessa cosa però va
beh non fa niente lo chiamiamo bnp fp
qualsiasi modo vuol dire community
ok community e quindi c'è scritto la
prossima cosa da fare e dire sì pratico
ma come faccio a essere pratico con una
con un tema di community cioè community
e pratico non sanno nella stessa frase e
avevo detto prima a fare una cosa
conoscete la persona alla vostra
sinistra
presentatevi se non la conoscete
presentatevi subito
e adesso facciamo la stessa identica
cosa sulla vostra destra
questo è giusto per farvi capire che
quello che faccio io dalla mattina alla
sera e mettere insieme persone come ho
fatto io adesso in questo momento con
130 persone raccontandovi un'opportunità
di conoscenza
questo uno più uno che fa più di due e
questo l'obiettivo che mi pongo tutti i
giorni in tutti gli eventi in tutte le
attività quindi ti racconto la storia
che dal 2014 ha portato più di quaranta
eventi su milano sul digital venture
capitals entrepreneurship and ha avuto
più di 80 speaker che sono venuti alle
nostre attività più di 4 mila e 800
partecipanti hanno partecipato hanno
passato del tempo con noi questa
iniziativa si chiama start up line
milano è fondamentalmente quale è stato
il primo evento che sembrano tutti i
numeri bellissimi ma quando quando
diciamo 4.800 partecipanti in 40 eventi
sono tantissime persone e questo è il
primo evento non so se lo vedete bene se
li con date sono dodici sono dodici
partecipanti 30 registrati nessuno è
venuto però va beh non fa niente
il il divano era il nostro posto dove
facevamo l'intervista ma bellissimo quel
divano e naturalmente è stato preso
dalle pattumiere o qualcosa del genere
però quello che voglio dire
semplicemente che quando abbiamo
iniziato noi a parlare di start up
questo era la situazione fuori era un
deserto totale nessuno raccontava niente
non c'erano casi di successo
era un modo di buttare un po di soldi
della paghetta e quindi questo erano le
persone che parlavano di start up in
quel momento quattro amici al bar
probabilmente non esattamente e giovani
stato un momento difficilissimo pensate
di raccontare di start up quando tutte
le altre persone pensano alla crisi ha
qualcosa di se perdiamo il lavoro è cosa
già mi ha assolutamente non bellissimo e
allora ho iniziato nello stesso deserto
ho fatto questa foto è il vero sauro e
alto così e quindi non è un progresso un
problema di prospettiva a lottare ea
cercare di spingere a cercare di
crescere e ho fatto un percorso questo
percorso e non è così assolutamente
questo è il percorso è veramente una
startup dovrebbe avere ma non sa mai
dove al quinto step al quinto scalino
già inizia a raddoppiare tutto è
purtroppo non è così molto spesso anzi è
totalmente il contrario e questo è stato
il mio percorso
una bella salita salita bella ripida una
bella discesa ripidissima e poi tante
opportunità di dire ma a sto punto
lasciamo non è il caso naturalmente non
serve non funziona nessuno vuole parlare
di start up in italia non ha senso poi
adesso piano piano ho iniziato a
prendere coda con
con partnership che ho fatto un sacco di
parma ci abbiamo fatto un sacco di
stretta di mano con persone dire ma
facciamo le cose insieme invece falle
separate
un evento due persone anzi due eventi da
quattro persone molto peggio di fare un
evento da 8 no stiamo stiamo i numeri
sono un po più alti abbiamo organizzato
gli eventi verticali su dei temi come i
crociati in come l'influenza marketing
per cerca di prendere più nicchie
possibili per cerca di portare persone
le nostre attività e poi abbiamo chiesto
aiuto abbiamo detto alle persone che
vivono i nostri eventi
se volete continuare a venire nostri
eventi dovete aiutarci perché sono
questi eventi moriranno se volete darci
una mano suggerite c speakers ferite ci
location suggeriteci partnership da
poter fare quindi adesso parliamo di
cosa è successo ma faremo di cosa sta
succedendo questo evento a 208 persone
che abbiamo visto a dicembre su rosa
king e questo è stato un bel palco o
esattamente uguale a quel divano che
avete visto prima
proprio carino è la cosa più
interessante è cosa dicono i giornali
cosa dicono di noi gli opinion leader
una delle cose che leggo spesso è il
punto d'incontro gli innovatori milanesi
o una frase che la vedete ovunque è la
più grande e commenti di start up e
imprenditori in italia o quella che mi
piace di meno l'aperitivo esponenziale o
addirittura quando mi piace di più è un
gruppo di persone che vuole fare questo
per dirvi che facendo lezione ho creato
appunto dai queste da queste iniziative
ho creato una lezione di resilienza
cercando di potervi dare qualche insight
da portare a casa davvero professore è
quindi ho detto è la prima cosa è pensa
positivo
pensate positivo perchè se fallisce il
piano quasi ha scritto 25 ci sono altre
25 lettere dell'alfabeto inglese altri
23 in italiano l'idea è che se fallisce
una volta non c'è nessun problema di
farlo un'altra volta ci sono altre mille
opportunità fuori reinventa di tutti i
giorni la tua vita e la tua storia
scrivi da bene ma poi si è pronto a
cambiarla tante volte è meglio mettere
un po di bianchetto e ri scriverci sopra
o prendere un altro foglio e iniziare
questo ha salvato tante aziende salva
tanti imprenditori dal fallimento totale
ricorda sempre i tuoi valori i valori
sono l'unica cosa di cui nessuno ci
potrà mai privare i valori insieme alla
missione insieme alla tua mission
insieme al tuo molto
vivo il mio perché di prima la è
fondamentalmente la tua visione quindi i
tuoi obiettivi le tue i tuoi step sono
qualcosa che se diventano importanti se
diventano chiari nella tua testa diventa
il tuo modo il tuo piano di agire il tuo
piano strategico è tutto lì questo è un
puzzle che per me rappresenta un
problema
e se non ti focalizzi sulla soluzione di
iniziare a risolverlo rimarrà sempre un
problema rimarrà sempre un puzzle quindi
invece focalizzati sul problema
focalizza sulla soluzione
mantieni la calma calma e pazienza sono
le virtù dei forti mi dicevano sempre al
liceo è molto importante non diventare
iracondi non perdere la pazienza quando
si è rotta la ruota potevo perdere la
pazienza
meglio di no perché c'è un diluvio che
stava arrivando a 200 metri quindi
cambiato la ruota come la ferrari estate
avanti aiuta e sarà aiutato
se date una mano riceverete mani sedate
un'opportunità di crescita riceverete
altro fortuna di crescita aiutate
qualsiasi modo qualsiasi persona mi
dicevo 30 mila al giorno su posso avere
qualcuno possa avere un logo design e
per come si fa a fare una startup se non
rispondesse tutte queste persone
probabilmente nel momento in cui avrò
bisogno nessuno mi risponderà non avere
paura di fallire lo fanno anche i grandi
abbiamo visto come sono rovinato
l'estate i nostri cari calciatori
benissimo hanno fallito ma non possiamo
dirgli niente parte del gioco
sappiate che il 99 per cento le start up
non farà mai un euro nella propria vita
e quindi è l'altro un per cento deve
fare un po di soldi e quindi la lezione
di residenza a cosa serve serve per
cercare di continuare andare avanti e
cerca di costruire valore e quindi nel
secondo step della guida di come fare un
bellissimo the da crociera ringraziamo
gli organizzatori mi aiutate a fare un
applauso agli organizzatori
dai dai stati meravigliosi
continua la guida con riassumi riassumi
perché così chi ha interesse in queste
cose si ricorderà una sola frase si
ricorderà un qualcosa che hai detto
perfetto proviamoci allora ho bisogno
del vostro aiuto vi ricordate quel tnp
fp che fa schifo però va benissimo così
dividiamo la sala in due parti la prima
alla mia sinistra quindi questa parte la
parte destra del del pubblico dice
insieme a me insieme rivediamo insieme
la parte della mia alla mia destra da
sinistra il pubblico di censimenti che
insieme a me
noi noi poi questa parte qui sempre
possiamo più forte ragazzi possiamo e
quest'altra invece fare bravissimi
ragazzi e in tutti insieme di più
grazie mille a tutti
[Applauso]